suck gamers you ready for a challenge
don't laugh throughout this entire video
it's a pretty pie video so it should be
okay don't worry let's get into it
damn it I failed oh why do I laugh at
myself not even making a joke
failing again okay here we go
I called Billy a leash trash and these
MF s pulled up on me they all dressed
the same that's hilarious hey you want
to dress like me
Ricky God market I mean it's kind of
funny you never feel a leash was in this
town that she is the her whole career
would just be pure cringe yeah I said it
top ten in words
oh god I'm for 10 negative number nine
Nevada number eight Nissan number seven
number number six nine number five No
number four new number three Nigeria
nothing or two new number one nice won't
mention nobama
'no Bama you ever heard of that word my
favorite what a freakin Obama that was a
trip
that's good you gotta appreciate the
teacher coming in as well
no don't slap him what surely that would
be helpful in a situation in the life
and death situation feel free to slap me
like that no problem no judgment
I always seen this but it's funny can
patter somersault cuz I want to do that
too Hey look another minecraft minute me
when she takes a good night at 6:30 p.m.
aha
baby please just take it slow good night
girl sorry we because it's got changes
the TV source from HDMI at one to HDMI
to my grandparents you did here crazy
son of a bit your day I was feel so
smart
whenever I figure it out and you know
finally you have someone that recognized
your pure genius thanks grandma
very cool okay I've seen this clip
floating around like it made me laugh
the first time it's from his face but
it's so clearly staged come on
it's funny cuz for a moment you think
it's real and they're like no okay
alright I've been here so I can relate
well that was a waste of time why would
you do that
Wow and why do I keep watching it bad
Oh God
it's like that feeling when you have a
big poo and you retract it in that's the
feeling I get when I watch this not good
don't ask me why I retract my poo that's
very perfect formation thank you very
much this is like a weird millennial
version of metamorphosis by Franz Kafka
Mike Earl hard Microsoft well that's
funny
come on that's funny I had a reason with
you getting that guy's now pitch speak
when you're playing on the realm and
your homie kills your dog game mode
created oh my god that's an amazing edit
that's so good
I'm sorry in the future meme accounts
will be the one who's making movies
they're the only ones that's qualified
no one got an actual education
what is he doing what an [ __ ] look at
it look at this dude
I can't yeah I can't tell if the cat
wants to hold hands or if the cat is
trying to piss off the dog or he was
trying to calm the dog be like brush
yeah oh no oh no
[Music]
Oh a humble people Popo the last one to
go hey aha goddess is gonna be one of
those worthy like eat the diamond or
something
don't dig down there you go I watched my
original series now where I find
diamonds and I immediately so dig it
straight out and I'm just like I get it
now
ok I get it giant ecologist where their
patient leaves the room oh there's
another one me after I do this with my
store can the internet stop oh my god
the dog is melting the dog is being
fellow singing star Oh dog why doggy not
feel so good I'm very confused just want
that to be clear I don't understand next
clip when the e girl you donated your
life savings to gets a new highest
donated on earth stream
oh my god thank you thank you so much
thanks Jared oh hope it was worth it
[ __ ] used real memes okay wait so
it's definitely not dead they're never
dead oh my god
I live the same as spiders here in UK we
have spiders everywhere
they just don't die any better poison
you know those things are filled with
gas and they can actually explode and
penetrate your shrinks your spectrum
I think there's photos of that on the
internet let me see exploding gas chair
you're probably sitting on one right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah look at this boy
killed yeah
get a nice chair all right all I'm gonna
say is get a nice chair get off your
chairs now and get a nice one $3.99
that's a great price if you think about
the consequences if you end up like this
person you'll be like damn it I should
have paid 399 yes I'm using fear and
tragedy to sell my own merch thank you
show me some was that stage damn it let
me watch again show me something
well did it hit it if you hit it that we
say
thank you what'd I tell you what'd I
tell you $3.99 what i buyed to get off
your chairs now stand please stand
oh god I unless you want that happen to
you then feel free to sick thought mom
smoking that's funny
so obviously we kept going it's like you
yes I am just laughing smirking at
videos and that's all the commentary I'm
giving to these videos thank you very
much let's keep watching
I was good I didn't make my laugh but it
was good
[Music]
what my god oh my god
hamburger zone what are they saying
things or the Hamrick zone what is he
saying
oh the handbrake your handbrake on your
arm would you just even Hambrick don't
understand well I'd say MREs sure it's
not getting weirder oh my god what why
and people find it weird to explain what
I do online okay that was good I like
that one that's a good one
again oh my god that was amazing
he has a beard net oh my god that's
dangerous how do you come up with these
ideas and on that note we will end this
episode I hope you guys had fun much
like if you did subscribe represent
commissar sweetiepie
check out the merch epically 100,000,000
club merch you don't want to miss out
baby see you guys tomorrow goodbye see
you then I prom I'll be here
don't worry see you well you haven't
tried to pursue milady at City after 50
million outros much now just now it's
still relevant just download it